logan gilbert he has been turned up but
i i don't think he builds it very much
he is definitely calm cool and collected
out there regardless of situation
that'll bring up center fielder starling
martine not in the starting lineup last
night the wind-up and the one-two to
martina swing and a miss for strike
three logan gilbert with his first
strikeout of the ball game he fans
starly martay and the athletics have two
down
right away here in the top of the first
inning and here is first baseman matt
putting the finishing touches on a great
year
now the wind-up and the 0-1 pitch
swinging a line shot of the right field
over hannigar leaps up in the air and he
makes the catch that's going to retire
the side that ball had some carry to it
frankie montas will pitch for the is
here tonight and trying to keep a great
run going in his last seven starts he's
4-0 he's 13-9 on the year so here's kyle
seeger
gomez up inside it comes back over the
inside corner at 97 perfect pitch
he put it right on the mid seeger didn't
like it
and that's not number two here's
hanukkah is batting at 252 and 38 home
runs 95 rbis
the pitch to mitch hanniger here it is
and that swung out of missing a fast
ball away back-to-back is for montas
the mariners go down in the first and
after one the ace and the mariners no
score and here's shortstop josh harrison
and now the right-hander is 2-2 on the
way swing and a miss for strike three
and there's strikeout number two for
logan gilbert
and that'll bring up third baseman matt
chapman
here's the stretch and the one-two to
champion swing and a miss for strike
three and that's it for the a's
strikeout number three for logan gilbert
he gets harrison and chapman here in the
second he got martay in the first what a
start for the kid
seth brown leads it off in the third for
the a's
and here's the k-chant going on here
gilbert goes into his wine the 2-2 to
chad brown swing and a miss struck him
out
one out here in the third logan
gilbert's fourth strikeout and now ty
france will bat one ball two strikes
frankie fires and a split swung on and
missed and the inning is over
no runs no hits no errors of man left
and frankie gets his third k
of the night three in the books a's and
mariners no score now kelnick
one of his 14 home runs against
montas
here comes the o2 swing and a miss high
octane upstairs at 97.
and that gets kelnick for out number two
and strikeout number four for frankie
motas
he's one away from tying the single
season record in oakland history for a
right-handed pitcher
and now here's abraham toro
ranking back to the set at the belt and
to the switch hitting toro he deals a
split
swung on foul tip held on by gomes and
the inning is over back-to-back case and
frankie now has five on the night we've
got four in the books
at t-mobile park the a's and mariners
still no score tony tonight is over two
popped out to center field flight out to
left
the 2-1 pitch and tony hits it to right
field hits it well haniger back at the
track he'll turn and watch it fly
and tony camp gives the a's the lead
with a right field home run in the top
of the sixth inning in seattle
it's one nothing athletics
tony kemp comes through once again for
the a's this is a big out to get
harrison for the third out
righty on righty here 2-0 pitch
swing on line drive right field
henniger's right there couple steps
makes a catch inning over
a run on the home run by tony kemp they
leave a runner we go bottom six two
three four coming up ty france lead it
off against frankie montas one for two
with the base here at the left and a
strikeout montage since it'll wind first
pitch swung on a little looper center
field coming on martay backing up his
camp harvest glove
and ty france is aboard with the tying
run
tony was doing a hard back pedal
and at the last second reached up and it
went off the tip of his glove so here's
seeger
and now the pitch by frankie and the 2-2
delivery
ready the paws to turn in a split swung
out of miss a perfect pitch
great action down and down and away
six strikeouts for montas
and now the single season leader for the
a's among right-handed pitchers and
strikeouts with 206. mitch haniger at
the plate
strikeout will base it to right tonight
one for two
months ready
first pitch to mitch swing on dribbled
to the shortstop harrison flips this oh
he bobbled the flip
and they get the out but he tried to get
the ball out of his glove
and it's stuck and he one hopped it to
tony kemp they get the out at second
foot is off the back
does it get back on it's off it's off
he's in there
first and second for the mariners one
out for jared kellnick
out to right center
with the drive pender can make the catch
francis coming home hannigan's behind
him jared kellnick
and now here comes seth brown to the
plate
that one's hit high to right field
haniger's back hannigar at the wall he
leaps it is girl
seth brown a two out solo shot we're
tied at two
his 18th of the year and we start all
over at 2-2
here is mr france
ty france looking hitterish up there
first pitch breaking ball swing on
driven deep to left
at the track the cannon makes the catch
and strolling home is dylan moore and
the mariners retake the lead at three to
two ty france gets the job done his 73rd
rbi baroners in front again here in the
seventh
and that will bring up second baseman
abraham toro now the two-nothing pitch
toro swinging to drive deep into right
field pinder going back the track to the
wall goodbye baseball
abraham toro
his 11th home run of the season the
mariners get the insurance run they're
looking for everybody on their feet it's
now the mariners four
and the ace two
it was brown who hit a home run in the
top of the seventh inning that tied the
game in two
and the o2 pitch swaying in a fly ball
left center field kel nick over jared is
there he
makes the catch and it just continues my
oh my
the mariners win it four to two they
sweep aside the oakland a's and the
mariners stay
a half game out in the wild card race
you